when did you realize you were a
storyteller whoa
when did I realize I was a storyteller
probably in high school I think my
storytelling comes from two different
places so it comes from obviously family
and I come from a tradition of
trash-talking joke telling old Jewish
you know crazy like my grandpa my
grandma just seen around the table just
telling stories and so there's that side
of me and then the other side of me is
growing up in the 90s early 2000s like
around a lot of rappers and poets and
wannabe comedians and like you know I
grew up in DC and so like every white
Jewish boy of my generation I wanted to
be a rapper and quickly realized I
couldn't rap too good so then I got into
writing and poetry and storytelling and
from there it was kind of merging these
worlds and finding like every one you
got to find your voice and just kind of
bringing it all together did you get any
pressure from family or peers to do
something else yeah I mean yeah my
family my mom still is like you make
money on this and I'm like well not
really but a little bit you know enough
to pay the bills so I used to I was
gonna be a teacher I was gonna be I
worked in schools for a long time with
different nonprofit organizations and so
I you know my my folks they you know
they you know they want you to have
health care and you know they want you
to you know be okay and pay the rent and
all those things and so far I've been
able to do that most months through my
art
and but not they also for the most part
I'm blessed that my parents and my
family are mostly pretty supportive and
they understand it's like you got to do
what calls you you got to do what makes
sense and mostly my mom's like I don't
think your stuff is very funny you but
you know nice try and better luck next
time so they're supportive not what I'm
saying is my mom's supportive in theory
but she's like well I don't think it's
that good but I'm glad other people like
it son keep doing what you do in some
ways do you think that's almost helpful
because what if you had something where
was a pat on the back and everything you
do is amazing and then a while yeah no
my my family and my peers and my people
we don't have a lot of false praise and
as good as a writer I need I need the
honest feedback and my wife oh she's the
toughest critic and that's what I'm like
like giving me to me Straight No Chaser
and then it's also good to have as a
writer and I have this with Yvonne in
the writers room it's also important to
have those times where you where I can
say I want to show you a draft and I
don't want all the feedback just yet I
just want to show it to you and like
don't like tear me down just yet just
like tell me you like three things is
there anything in here worth keeping and
like we'll go off that so I think it's
important to have both the like harsh
feedback but also the like safe spaces
I'm trying some new stuff out what do
you think so I get that definitely at
home and at work
do you not like to have yes people
around you I mean well you know I like
to have some people who you know our
support you know it's good like I said
you need both you gotta have the people
who are supportive all the time who are
just like let's try it but I don't know
I don't really have yes people around me
Saul
you know when when I find those people
when I get an assistant and a manager
and my agents and and I have yes people
I'll come back and let you know I
haven't I haven't got there yet and I
think that's okay
you